the president day good morning
the session is open
good morning colleagues and colleagues I
remind you that on 24 October 2019
I decided pursuant to the regulation to
improve a sanction and the honorable
lock who had shown
aggressive and respectful
behavior towards his colleagues in
this institution  grossly violating
a rule of conduct during the
discussion on the Turkish military operation
in north east Syria held on
23 October on 6 November
the honorable shock lodged an
appeal at his meeting yesterday
the bureau examined the
appeal and  my decision confirmed
and the sanction resumes from
today preparation of the
European council meeting of 12 and 13 December
greeting of the representatives of
the council commission
the agenda is the preparation
of the meeting I remind you that it is
possible to present requests for
intervention  according to the procedure you
give us the blue card questions and
util  using
both the standard registration system and the
electronic system the instructions are
available at the entrance of the murders
in the hemicycle I would immediately give the floor in the
name of the council to the minister super
heinen please shut up